vamos ahora a hablar del caso de bani a
escobar se ha convertido en el rostro
más visible de la reciente ola de
violencia contra las mujeres en méjico y
vuelve a poner sobre la mesa a los
feminicidios que no se detienen en el
país de enero a marzo 2022 se
registraron 229 presuntos homicidios en
méxico según el reporte más reciente del
sistema nacional de seguridad pública
los estados con más casos son méxico
seguido por nuevo león y veracruz además
de los feminicidios se reportó que el
pasado primero de mayo fue el día más
violento de 2022 en la nación azteca con
110 asesinatos al menos y a propósito y
durante el día internacional de la
libertad de prensa la organización human
right watch denunció que los periodistas
sufren una escalada de violencia él
llama al gobierno federal mexicano a
tomar medidas para protegerlos para ello
entonces quiere darle la bienvenida a
nuestro programa lucero circle lópez
slim frío ella es integrante del
observatorio y también presidenta de la
asociación humana sin violencia gracias
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 el lucero le
pregunta entonces a que sea atribuye
este auge de la violencia en méxico
porque se está recrudeciendo
bueno antes que nada muchas gracias hay
una situación realmente de una violencia
generalizada en nuestro país no es de
ahora es ahora aunque ahora hay una
agudización más grave porque también hay
una negación por parte del gobierno
federal a considerar que es una
prioridad o de una de las
situaciones más complejas que hay que
atender desde la cabecera desde desde el
presidente y todo lo que compone al
gabinete pero esto no ha sucedido en lo
que va de su administración pero más o
menos tenemos alrededor de más de 10
años que hemos venido observando que se
ha venido
incrementando la violencia contra las
mujeres por diversas razones y
justamente esa diversidad de razones una
de ellas tiene que ver con la violencia
criminal que existe a lo largo y ancho
del país que no se ha tenido una
respuesta pues no se más acorde a
atender esa violencia criminal que
justamente en esos espacios donde está
cooptado por ya sea el crimen organizado
o por el narcotráfico lo que ha generado
esta exposición y aumento de casos de
mujeres que son no localizadas o que
están en situación de búsqueda y
principalmente de agresiones sexuales
que es lo que estamos viendo con los
casos que se están manifestando que se
han hecho más mediáticos en nuestro país
principalmente en nuevo léon como esto
lo señaló también este veracruz pero
también tenemos una situación muy
compleja en
diversos estados más la mayoría de los
estados están en este mecanismo de la
alerta de violencia de género que
realmente no ha funcionado para lo que
se tiene que hacer que es justamente
evitar que asesinan a las mujeres y esto
ha sido una situación bastante compleja
de todos los días y luz héroe le quiero
preguntar cuáles son estas principales
causas de feminicidio en méxico y por
qué digamos las autoridades sabiendo
esto los feminicidios lamentablemente en
mexico de larga data realmente no toman
cartas en el asunto para evitar que más
mujeres mueran a causa de la violencia
en general y también sólo por el caso de
ser mujer
claro aquí hay una uno de ellos
fundamentalmente y nosotros lo
observamos es que nuestro país no se ha
construido ni diseñado una política
pública que atienda fundamentalmente la
violencia familiar el origen de los
feminicidios en su mayoría está
relacionado justamente con una relación
de pareja con quien uno hizo un proyecto
de vida posiblemente estas mujeres con
quien construyeron y crearon hijos por
así decirlo y estas son las que las
asesinas en todo lo que llevamos de este
tiempo que se ha utilizado la alerta de
violencia de género pues hemos ido
aprendiendo y hemos ido construyendo
conocimiento alrededor de ello y una de
las principales causas es la nueva
atención a la violencia familiar y las
tres o tres aspectos fundamentales
dentro de esta situación de violencia
familiar es cuando las mujeres deciden
separarse o pedirles el divorcio a sus
parejas cuando hay exigen la pensión
alimenticia y la otra es cuando es la
guardia y custodia son tres aspectos que
generan una condición en que las mujeres
puedan ser mucho más agredidas
de la vida por parte de sus parejas o
los padres de sus hijos y la otra que
tiene que ver es fundamentalmente son
dos razones por las cuales consideramos
que no hay una política no se ha tendido
esto tampoco que tiene que ver con las
profundas desigualdades que tienen las
mujeres fundamentalmente con la
feminización de la pobreza y también la
inclusión y sumatoria de las mujeres a
este sistema del crimen organizado que
puede ser que estén en un asunto de
venta o de trasiego de las drogas y que
esto está generando justamente pues
estos incrementos este elevados de
homicidios en contra de las mujeres que
tienen otro aspecto dentro de esta de
alta criminalidad y que es muy poco
estudiado por así decirlo por la
complejidad que implica no el lucero
vamos a hablar entonces ahora de este
caso mediático el de la joven de baní
escobar cuáles sido el papel de las
autoridades que investigan este caso que
han dicho hasta ahora como lo han
catalogado porque es el caso pues tiene
tiene muchos misterios digamos en torno
a él y todavía no se ha esclarecido
realmente qué pasó con ella esta noche
cuando se fue de fiesta con sus amigas y
apareció ya puede ser muerta en un
tanque de agua de un hotel
bueno fundamentalmente creo que es este
caso en particular se ha vuelto
emblemático porque es justamente señala
varias deficiencias desde
principalmente de las autoridades
locales que bueno han hecho realmente
todos los y se han empeñado en hacer
todos los errores posibles en los actos
de investigación en primer lugar porque
no tienen o no saben cómo empezar y cómo
analizar y cómo llegar a un por ejemplo
toda esta documentación de las pruebas y
guardar y tener la seguridad de la
confidencialidad del caso la otra es
esta posición que a mí me preocupa
muchísimo que son de las fiscalías
justamente que vienen haciendo este
trabajo en el cual
pues no tienen ninguna deja dejemos más
allá de los protocolos no tienen una
sistematización ni una serie de atención
colocada dentro de las instituciones que
permitan justamente
atención más no solamente inmediata
cuando se presenta el caso sin oportuna
en términos preventivos y la otra que
tiene que ver en términos de seguridad
pública que a mí me parece bastante
grave es que tampoco hay una
intervención no saben por dónde
intervenir las de seguridad pública de
hecho no solamente ha estado pasando a
ustedes han estado observando también
que en la secretaría de seguridad
pública al parecer en lugar de atender a
los llamados de violencia que hacen de
auxilio a las mujeres a través de las
líneas telefónicas lo que está pasando
es que ellos van y lo que hacen es
agredir a las mujeres que se manifiestan
justamente para que algunos gobiernos
atiendan estos casos y no lo están
haciendo no rápidamente del lucero el
caso de los periodistas ayer digamos a
propósito del día de la libertad de
prensa
bueno este a mi me parece también hay
una cuestión bastante grave sistemática
y que también aquí refleja dos cosas una
la posición clara que existe dentro de
el gobierno federal a través del
presidente de hacer este división
divisionismo de hacer esta
contraposición de justamente hacer estos
pues se puede decir que críticas muy
fuertes para desestimar
la labor periodística y no solamente
pasa a nivel federal sino en cada uno de
los estados esta corrupción que existe
entre autoridades y si carísimos que
justamente lo que está generando es que
lava la prensa se ve amenazada en ese
sentido dada la violencia generalizada
que no está siendo tomada en cuenta